- So good morning everyone.
Thanks for joining us today.
For this session,
we're gonna be predominantly talking about
streaming at scale,
and focusing really on Amazon CloudFront
to do that delivery.
So my name's Jamie Mullan,
I'm a specialist solutions
architect here at AWS.
And I'm joined buying my
colleague John Councilman,
who is also another specialist
solutions architect.
And with Jes Palmer, who is from NESN
to talk about what scale
really means to them.
So we're gonna be
thinking about, you know,
those live scale...
Large scale events, sorry.
Those critical events
that just must be delivered
without any issues.
And also those events with
many, many viewers globally.
But it's easy, right?
You have a contribution feed,
you do some processing on it,
and it just goes to a viewer.
That's it.
What else do you really need? (laughing)
Well, it is a little bit
more complicated than that.
And we're gonna look at,
you know, some of those design decisions
that kind of help you
influence that delivery.
But scale can mean different
things to different customers.
For example, it could be
millions of concurrent viewers
or it could be billions
of minutes consumed.
But no matter the scale,
we frequently get asked by customers
like, how do I monitor my distribution?
How do I protect my content at the edge?
How do I scale to that global audience
with that high uptime?
And finally, can I
monetize that live content?
You might be wondering,
like what architectural
decisions do I need to make
to make sure an event is successful?
Glad to say you're in the
right session this morning.
But what happens if we get our
job wrong as video architects
or solutions architects
and video engineers?
Well, viewers might get pixelation,
degraded viewer experience,
and/or arguably, my personal
most frustrating experience
is that spinning buffer wheel.
So we're gonna be focused predominantly
on delivering content through
Amazon CloudFront today.
If you don't know,
CloudFront is our content
delivery network, or CDN.
CloudFront is a large global network
with over 750 edge locations.
All the edge locations
are connected over a
redundant and private backbone
back to AWS regions.
And CloudFront can be used to accelerate
applications of all types,
whether that's static assets
like video files, image files,
CSS, JavaScript.
And they can be cached in edge locations,
and delivered really
closer to those end users.
CloudFront could also be used
for dynamic traffic requests too.
So the talk is gonna kind of revolve
around this steel thread
architecture today.
And we're gonna look at
different design decisions
throughout the workflow.
Advanced warnings toward the
video folk in the audience,
we're gonna start downstream this time.
So first off, we're
gonna look at delivery.
You know, some OTT providers
deliver these streams for a cost,
whether that's subscription
or pay-per-view.
So you naturally care
about, you know, security,
protecting their content.
Next we're gonna look
at encode origination.
So for big events or big
sporting events in particular,
this is really, really
critical and important.
You want to design your workflow
to ensure the event is
successfully delivered...
Delivered successfully, sorry.
And then finally, we're
gonna look at ingest.
Simply put, if you have no
feed, you have no event, right?
So we'll explore different ways
to make ingest more reliable.
But the first thing that
we're gonna kick off with
is monitoring.
And I ask that question,
how do we know
we're actually delivering
that event successfully?
- Okay, thanks Jamie.
My name is John Councilman.
I'm a solutions architect with AWS.
And we wanna look at how can we gauge
whether our live event was successful.
As you can see here,
there's a lot of data available
to us from our platform.
Things like exit errors, video
start failures, rebuffering.
A lot of this stuff either
comes from the client itself,
the video player,
or it's coming from CloudFront.
So this might be presented as logs,
it might be beacons.
It's coming from a lot
of different directions.
We have a lot of data, which
is good, but it's also bad.
We have a lot of data, how
do we deal with it all?
So we're gonna look into
some features on CloudFront
and some other AWS services
to see how we can actually
make sense of everything here.
So first off, every event needs good data.
We need a dashboard,
we need real time access to logs,
and we need to be able to
analyze the event after the fact.
So first off, with metrics,
CloudFront actually uses
CloudWatch to deliver metrics.
So I like to use CloudWatch dashboards,
kind of I compare it to an
actual dashboard like on my car.
When we go camping, we
actually pull a trailer.
And I'm constantly looking at
two gauges on my dashboard.
I'm looking at the fuel level
because I'm getting like five
miles per gallon on my car,
and I'm also looking at the
transmission temperature.
So if there's an issue,
'cause I don't normally
pull a camper every day,
I know exactly what to look at.
I know if it gets too hot,
I don't need to put gas in the car,
it's actually the transmission
I need to pull over.
So the same is true for a streaming event.
Most of these only last a few hours.
In the case of like a sports event,
we need to know right away
whether we have a problem with an origin,
whether it's CloudFront
or if we're using something
like DRM or advertising,
whether there's a problem with
that affecting our stream.
So dashboards are the
first line of defense,
so we know where to look,
where to dive deeper.
Just speaking of diving deeper,
CloudFront, it supports
real time access logs.
And as you can see here,
it actually uses Amazon
Kinesis to deliver this.
It's delivering realtime
logs for millions of viewers,
which is extremely difficult.
Kinesis is designed exactly for this.
So when you configure
realtime logs in CloudFront,
it's gonna ask for a Kinesis endpoint.
And the nice thing about Kinesis
is you can have multiple consumers
pulling that data in parallel.
So we can have realtime dashboards,
we can have observability
platforms, analytics platforms.
We can also share this data
in real time with partners,
whether they're looking
at viewership in real time
or they're looking at advertising data
and they need that
information in real time.
So then with this real time data,
we can see issues before
they become a big problem
and react to it.
And we can adjust our platform
in real time as needed
to handle these largest events.
Then lastly, access logs.
These are stored in batches on S3.
As you can see here, the delay
is usually in the minutes.
Nice thing about S3 is we can...
We can tie Athena into it
so we can query all these
logs using standard SQL.
And we can set life
cycles on the S3 bucket.
So we can have events from
weeks or even years ago
stored in archival.
So we can compare this previous event
to one that we did, you know,
maybe a week or a month ago,
and see how we've improved
and find out lessons learned.
We can do some
troubleshooting after the fact
and we can pull reporting
easily using Athena.
And then lastly, console reports.
This is in the CloudFront console
and is useful for just, you know,
figuring out trends, viewership,
cache fill ratio between
events and monthly reports.
So that's always available as well.
Okay.
Next, I spoke a lot about
CloudFront and its logs.
But typically CloudFront only has access
to things that are in the
HTTP header or geo information
such as the user agent,
the client's IP address,
maybe the geo region,
the ASN, cache status.
And this has always been logged,
whether it's in real time
logs or in the S3 logs.
But I mentioned earlier about the client.
The client has a lot of
really valuable information
such as like the throughput.
The client being the player
like dash.js or hls.js,
it's making decisions
about which video bit rate to pull
based on what it knows your
home internet bandwidth is.
And having that kind of information
along with session ID and content ID
is extremely valuable for
figuring out what's going on.
But in the past, this
information was only available
using like SDKs from third parties,
and it was sending it using
beacons to some other platform.
So you had CloudFront or
CDN logs in one bucket,
then you had all the player
information in another bucket,
and really no way to tie the two together.
And trust me it's extremely
difficult to do that.
It can be done but it's not easy.
But what if there were a way
to combine all this client information
such as you know, the bit rate
being used, the session ID,
which rendition,
whether it's HD or standard
definition content,
and combine that with all the information
that CloudFront knows about,
such as HTTP headers, you
know, user agent IP address.
And that's exactly what CMCD,
Common Media Client Data
attempts to solve.
It's actually a standard now
that was created by CTA Wave,
which has created a lot of other standards
that Jamie's gonna talk about later,
that pretty much all CDNs adhere to
and the players know about.
So using CMCD, all this information...
(audience applauds)
All this information is
kept in the same log line.
So all this content ID, session ID,
is transmitted as query
strings or headers to the CDN.
And since it's standardized,
we know what to do with it already.
And a lot of partners
that you might be using
for a monitoring platform
already know how to deal with CMCD.
So CloudFront has supported
CMCD for quite a while.
If you look here on the left,
this is a realtime log configuration.
You can see here, we
have additional fields
that are standard CMCD fields.
They're all prefixed with CMCD.
And you can just choose
some of them or all of them
depending on what your client's sending.
And all this information will
be added to the realtime logs
that we're sending through to Kinesis.
And again, a lot of partners
already support this
on their logging platforms.
And we actually have a reference sample
that already knows
how to deal with this
additional information
in the log lines.
And it has a realtime dashboard
that actually refreshes in real time
based on all this data
to show exactly what's happening
with the client and with the CDN.
So you can scan the QR code here
or just search for the video observability
with CMCD and CloudFront,
and try it out on your own distribution
being a reference sample
that's free to use,
and you can edit it at
Willow's open source.
(coughs)
Excuse me.
So it is easy.
CMCD is easy.
Again, you saw it on the realtime logs.
In CloudFront, it's just
adding those additional fills
and having a consumer dashboard
that knows how to access it.
This is an example
on some of the players
you might be using today.
These are two popular open source players,
hls.js and dash.js.
And as you can see here,
configuring CMCD
is just a matter of adding
a few more key value pairs
when you instantiate your player.
In the case of hls.js,
which is one I'm very familiar with,
it's just a CMCD structure.
But notice specifically on the left,
we have a session ID now.
That's actually a common
or standard CMCD field,
which is extremely useful.
If you are using CMCD and
not using session ID today,
how I suggest you do it,
that's usually pulled
from like your content management system
for that particular user
when they start a session.
When you include this
session ID in a field,
you actually can find all the logs
that are tied to a specific user.
So you can see individual user's journey
from starting to playback
your stream till end.
How many times they switched bit rates,
rebuffered, stalled, all that.
So you can figure out
individual user journeys
and use the same information
to find other users' journeys
as well based on session ID,
which wasn't possible before
since the client information
and the CD information
were stored in separate locations,
so it makes it super easy.
Okay, so now this is
security requirements.
We talked about logging.
We've vetted visibility
to our CloudFront distribution.
We wanna make sure all of our users,
our valid users are receiving
the best possible experience.
But we don't want our invalid users
that are trying to steal our streams,
take down our...
You know, steal our content
or take down our streams.
We really wanna stop them
from receiving our content
and harming the experience
that other users are experiencing.
So what do these users look like?
Well, ideally in a perfect world
you'd have your origin
server behind CloudFront,
you'd have CloudFront
delivering a standard URL,
in this case it's HLS and index.m3u8.
And all of your paid or subscribed users
would pull the content.
That's not the case, as we all know.
We see users that are trying
to re-stream the content.
So they're a paid valid user
coming from maybe a particular IP address,
pulling our content and then
re-streaming it to their users
who are probably paying them.
Obviously, we don't want that.
And then invalid regions.
Not only have we not really
designed our infrastructure
to maybe operate in a different country
for scalability purposes,
when we have viewers from invalid regions,
they're messing up our stats.
So they might be having a bad experience
and it's going to mess up
our analysis of how our...
You know, whether our
event was a success or not.
If we see viewers coming
from outside of the country
with high latency numbers,
that's gonna affect all of our reporting.
And then lastly,
Jes is gonna talk about it in a little bit
with rights holders.
There might be even legal consequences
of delivering content
outside of your country
where your contract states
that you can only deliver
in a certain region,
you only have rights to deliver
in maybe a specific state.
In the case of sporting events
or maybe a specific country.
I know in the past dealing
with some customers
when the Olympics are involved,
the contract for theirs
is extremely specific
when it comes to regions
and the security required
to deliver that content.
So again, rights holders
are very important as well.
And then lastly, unpaid users
that have found the way around
any CloudFront restrictions
and are able to go directly to the origin.
So obviously, we don't want that,
but also if you're able to
go directly to the origin,
it's going to affect the
experience of everybody
'cause the origin should be
protected behind CloudFront,
where CloudFront serves
99 plus percent of the
traffic from its cache.
So the origin server
should never be delivering
content directly.
Okay, so what tools do
we have available to us?
So first of all, my son, he's seven.
He's actually been home
from school recently
on vacation for break.
And he tends to find ways
to stream YouTube when
he is not supposed to.
So I've tried the firewall
rules on my home internet.
And eventually ended up
just locking the remotes
in the office and networks.
So that's the tools I have.
But obviously on CloudFront
we don't have physical locking keys,
but we do have some ways
to restrict traffic.
So first off,
for anybody that's been
in the CloudFront console,
you've probably noticed the
geo restrictions built in.
So that's just built into the
distribution in the console
through the API if you're using that.
So this is a way
to quickly allow or
disallow specific regions.
So if I'm delivering content
that's only allowed
to be delivered in the
United States, for instance.
I can go into CloudFront
and quickly add geo restrictions
to only allow the US,
or I could block specific
countries within there.
But the next layer we
can add on top of that,
the next tool in our tool chain
is AWS Web Application Firewall, WAF.
So in this case, we can
inspect anything coming in,
whether it's headers, IP addresses,
against a list.
And we also have lists
that you can subscribe to.
So we have to manage lists.
So we're already able to
allow specific regions
with geo restrictions,
but what about users who are using
maybe VPNs or proxies
to access our stream?
Using WAF, we can actually subscribe
the list of known VPN endpoints,
known proxy endpoints.
Or in the case of the re-streamer,
we found there that our IP address,
in the case of the example was 1, 2, 3, 4.
During the event, we can
actually add that IP address
to our own managed list
to block that user that's a re-streamer.
So WAF is really useful for
before, during, and after event.
So if you notice something specific,
you can add rules after the
fact for your next event.
Or in the case of the re-streamer,
you can actually modify
it during the event.
And then lastly,
for anything above and beyond
geo restrictions and WAF,
we have functions.
So CloudFront functions
run as JavaScript
actually on the ad server.
They're extremely low
latency and high performant.
And you're able to analyze the request
and/or responses coming from CloudFront
or to and from the origin.
And we've added key value stores as well.
So you're able to add data
to the key value store
using the API
and query that on edge function.
So we're gonna go into detail
about what this can be used for
when it comes to security in a minute.
So how do we secure our origin?
So as we all know, CloudFront
is origin agnostic.
So the origin could be anywhere, really.
So first off, if our origin is on-prem,
it's most likely on a public subnet.
So we obviously don't want
users to access that directly
so that again, it affects
the experience for everybody.
So the first thing we can do
is when you configure
your origin in CloudFront,
you can leverage HTTP headers.
That's then the origin level.
You can send a secret
header to the origin,
which the origin can validate
that this is actually in
fact coming from CloudFront.
And then you can also...
We also publish a list
of known IP addresses of
CloudFront edge servers
that you can add to your firewall on-prem
or on the origin itself
to allow only CloudFront to access it.
And then second,
if you're using something like
an application load balancer
or network load balancer,
maybe EC2 instances behind
those for your origin,
CloudFront now can leverage VPC Origins.
I don't know if everybody's aware of that.
And recently we've even
introduced cross region...
Cross account, sorry.
Cross account VPC Origins.
So if you're using multiple accounts,
CloudFront can access these origins
on a VPC from other accounts,
whether your accounts or
even partners' accounts,
which is huge,
'cause if your origin's not
even on a public subnet,
it can't be accessed in the first place.
And then lastly,
for some of our managed
services delivery media,
a lot of you use S3 for live
and on-demand media delivery
as well as elemental media package.
These can use origin access control.
So those are rule sets
that specifically allow only CloudFront
to access the content using signed URLs.
So I mentioned functions to take...
To basically expand upon security
above and beyond WAF and geo restrictions.
We see a lot of customers use
tokenization within functions
to further secure content.
So a token,
it's actually typically we see JWT used,
but there's quite a few formats out there.
And using functions, we're flexible.
You can basically implement
any sort of function
mechanism that you'd like,
whether it's JWT or some custom function
or some custom token that
you use across other CDNs.
So inside the token it
basically describes who you are,
what you're able to
watch, like a content ID,
and it would have a time limit.
So in case of JWT,
it's very easy to set a lifetime
that this token's only valid
for an hour, two hours, a full day.
And then it also provides,
you know, instructions on
where and what you can watch.
So ideally a user with a valid token,
they're sending all
this header information
and IP address information
in the CloudFront.
We're able to look up
their geo information
using geo headers,
they're configuring CloudFront.
And the token contains
all this information,
that they're able to watch
from a specific maybe US state,
that they're tied
to this particular IP
address or user agent.
And the function is
gonna validate all this
against the token and what
CloudFront knows about the user.
And if everything matches up,
the token wasn't modified
in transit from the user,
and the token hasn't expired,
then we just return a 200
OK within the function.
And then we have users
with invalid tokens.
Maybe they modify...
They tried to modify their token
and create their own token
and it's invalid 'cause
that wasn't signed correctly
or they're coming from
an invalid location.
You know, they may be
traveled with a valid token,
we signed it for their home use
on their cellular network
and they didn't receive a new token.
We'll actually return back
a manufacturer 401 unauthorized response
from the function itself
and immediately deny that user
before they even hit CloudFront
in their origin server.
And then lastly, we have a
user here with a share token.
Again, all these examples are using JWT,
which is really common,
which is easily implemented in functions.
This user has a shared token,
so they received the valid
token from the first user
and they're trying to reuse it,
and they might be living
in the same neighborhood
and using the same device,
so it happens to be valid for some reason.
But we noticed that this user...
This token is being used multiple
times and it's not valid.
We can actually add this token value
into the key value store.
So that's for us at a good use case
for key value stores and
functions is token revocation.
So you can insert this
token into a key value store
when you notice something wrong with it,
and it's just being used too many times.
And then you can have the
function return a 403 forbidden
if that token's in that key value store.
So again, this is a common
use case that we see
for tokenization JWT tokens.
But actually, we've recently
right before re:Invent
released CBO token support,
which is needed by the
common access tokens,
which again was created by CTA Wave.
So instead of having to
figure out how to write
a full token authentication
workflow in functions,
you can just tie directly into CBO,
which is supported as
a module in functions.
And the code is extremely minimal,
I was using it earlier and
it was just a few lines.
So that's natively supported now.
And against common access tokens
seems to be where the industry's headed
because it has been standardized now.
So we do have guidance
for security delivery at the edge on AWS.
So this takes all the work
we've done on functions
and does it for you.
So you can simply deploy this
onto your CloudFront distribution.
And we're going to
deploy all the functions
supporting JWT token support.
And we have a step function
available that's also deployed
that can automatically replicate tokens
that are being used incorrectly,
either multiple times
or from invalid users.
And we've even added a
full playback application,
sample application with video players
so you can try it out.
So you can just deploy this
using cloud formation
on your own distribution
and being open source,
you can modify it at will.
We even included SDKs
for your content management system
to create tokens and sign tokens
when you create playback URLs.
So check it out if you haven't.
And we're actually enabling support
for common access tokens
in this really soon.
That's coming shortly.
So yeah, just keep an eye
on it for the updates.
Okay, so I'm gonna hand it back to Jamie
for a talk on last mile capacity.
- So large scale...
Large scale events
can generate significant
internet traffic spikes
over a really short period of time,
with strained network links
that connect viewers to end content.
However, there might actually
only be a certain amount of capacity
between an internet exchange itself
and an ISP or a smaller city.
For example, ISPs continuously
optimize their networks,
but scaling capacity
for like those last minute big events
is understandably challenging, right?
Especially those events
that you know, you only need that capacity
for that short period of time.
When a network becomes
saturated or congested,
both packet loss and
increased latencies can occur.
And a result on the viewer experience
is things like quality drops, rebuffering,
or even those playback failures.
Remember, you can lean on
that monitoring approach
that John spoke about earlier
to try and help you identify
some of these issues.
But unless you own the network
or the underlying network
as an ATT provider,
this is something
that is really largely
out of your control.
Last year, however,
we introduced Embedded POPs.
And they overcome this challenge
by getting you closer
to those end viewers,
caching content directly
inside an ISP network,
and removing some of the
dependency on the network links
between the viewers and
the internet exchange.
If you didn't see it
on the POP map before,
we've got over 1,140 embedded POPs
across over a hundred ISPs
in more than 20 countries.
Because that distance to end
viewers is reduced further,
customers have already...
Customers that already
adopted in embedded POPs
have seen performance improvements too.
Because we're able to remove
some of the network dependency,
they're really great for
highly cachable content.
So we are very focused
on the media and entertainment
space today, obviously.
But you can also use them
for things like or
content like game delivery
and also software downloads.
So as part of the
onboarding of Embedded POPs,
we validate the workflow that
you want to use them for.
If it is a good fit,
the distribution is enabled
up by us in the backend.
However, there is some additional
work required on your side
to make sure your client application
can route to Embedded POPs.
The way that we recommend doing this
is integrating the client routing SDK
into your URL vending service.
So how does this work?
Well firstly, you need
to do that integration
of that client routing SDK
into your Euro vending service.
The QR code on the bottom right
is actually the link
to that SDK in GitHub,
if you're interested in
having a look at that.
So when the client application
requests a URL from that vending service,
the client in...
The client IP is encoded into the URL,
and it's annotated a CR
label in this diagram.
The client then performs a DNS lookup,
and Route53 and CloudFront
is able to decode that client
IP from that CR label itself.
Then CloudFront returns the best POP
based on that client IP.
Whether that's an embedded
POP if appropriate
or a traditional POP.
The client can then start
fetching content from CloudFront.
So in summary, embedded
POPs deliver cached content
directly from ISP networks,
improving performance
and overcoming
those potential last
mile capacity constraints
that you might have.
If you want to make use of embedded POPs,
I really urge you to
contact your account team
to help you validate...
Evaluate your workload
to see if it's suitable.
So typically, the next bottleneck
that we see is the origin.
Our aim really
is to offload as much traffic
as possible from the origin
so it has enough capacity
to serve requests at scale.
This is to prevent our origin
from becoming overwhelmed
and failing entirely.
Caching helps with this, of course.
And CloudFront uses tiered caching.
So we have edge locations,
we have regional edge caches,
but you can also use
something called Origin Shield
to further reduce that origin load.
Instead of regional edge caches
hitting the origin directly,
they go through Origin Shield,
and this provides a
better cache hit ratio,
reducing demand on your origin,
especially for those events,
you know, we've got a lot of scale.
So we've covered capacity,
we've covered reducing load
and ensuring viewers can
get a great experience.
It's time to really think about
how you design the rest of the platform
to provide just that, right?
To quote Werner Vogels,
"everything fails, all of the time."
Lots of customers approach us
by thinking about how many
nines you wanna design for.
But when you're thinking
about a media world,
this can also be very different
if you're designing a 24 by
seven channel for example,
and those event based channels.
And the other important part
is you've got the task of
really balancing the cost
and how much resilience
is really enough for you.
If your platform fails entirely,
users will be unable
to consume your content
and this might impact you in other ways
such as increased customer contact
or maybe even financially too.
For live events especially,
there's no real second
chance, we'll try again later,
that moment's just simply gone forever.
Like we discussed, things can go wrong.
So redundancy is really critical
to keep your stream up and running
so that you can deliver to your end users.
In this next example,
in particular we have two EC2s
and two availability zones
to try and help combat this.
We do see customers
deploy their own encoders
and origins in AWS,
but we do offer managed
services for media workflows.
They offload the challenges
of managing your own
customized infrastructure
and gives you capabilities and features
that we'll actually talk
about in a little bit.
These features are such as
like helping you provide
that best viewer experience
possible to end viewers.
So if you're not familiar with
AWS Elemental Media Services,
this is a typical workflow
for an ATT stream.
So we have AWS Elemental Media Connect,
which is our secure and reliable
transport service for live video.
That's then fed into AWS
Elemental Media Live,
which is our cloud-based, broadcast-grade
video processing service.
Then have AWS Elemental Media package,
and that is our just in time packaging
and origination service,
where you can implement
DVR-like functionality
and things like DRM.
And we've got Amazon CloudFront,
which is our CDM,
which we are predominantly
focusing on today.
And then viewers,
depending on what they wanna stream,
what manifests they need,
can pull different origin
endpoints from media package.
So with this,
we've kind of moved from ECT
and we've gone to AWS
Elemental Media Services.
So we no longer have to worry
about, you know, there's
underlying instances
and get all the benefits of
AWS Elemental Media Services.
For example, media live supports
across AZ synchronization and redundancy
for failover scenarios.
Customers running large events
tend to implement more redundancy
than just one regionally.
So we're gonna look at
what that multi-region
architecture might look like.
To help kind of speak this through,
I'm gonna look at a
typical failover scenario
that you might see,
but looking at where manual
intervention might be required.
So we have the same
architecture as what we had,
but obviously we've got
region one and region two
with Media Connect, Media
Live, and Media Package.
But we also have the addition
of Elemental Live or AWS Elemental Live,
which is our on-prem encoding appliance,
which in our case
is doing that venue contribution encoding.
So let's say something goes wrong
with one of the contribution
feeds going to region one
where the viewers are
currently streaming from.
Well, viewers connected to that
might start seeing black frames
instead of the actual video
content or real content.
But hopefully you've got a real...
An eyes on glass operations team
and they spot this issue early on
and decide that they
want to do that failover
to region two manually.
Remember, there's a time delay, right?
Between the issue occurring,
somebody spotting it,
and then also proactively
rectifying that situation.
So the failover occurs,
our viewers go to the URL vending service
and say I need a new URL,
and it returns one for region two.
However, there's a few challenges here
to kind of think about.
Number one, predominantly,
is the, you know,
it requires somebody
manually to do this, right?
And there's also a time delay
in detecting and then remediating it.
But not only that, when a viewer rejoins,
are they gonna have to go find
where they were viewing
in a stream, for example?
And then the timing might be misaligned
between the two anyway,
two regions anyway.
So how do you keep things in sync?
How do you do these things automatically?
So we're gonna explore this further,
but we're gonna start with time code.
Time code is time reference
that's embedded in each video frame.
Time code can be really important
in the media distribution world.
We want to use it for synchronization
in downstream components such
as the encoder and packager
to provide that frame accurate alignment.
So time code is part of the answer,
but how is it actually applied
to a failover scenario?
We have a feature that
can help manage this
and it's called seamless
cross region failover.
So we are gonna start with
the elemental live encoder on-prem.
And that's gonna use the
same time code source,
so both regions receive an
aligned contribution feed.
Media live is then
configured with Epoch locking
and uses the embedded timekeeper,
that timing source being that input lock.
And then CMAF ingests on the
output media package into...
Intermediate package, sorry.
And when you combine CMAF
ingest and Epoch locking,
it results in this regular
segmentation cadence
based on the Epoch time.
Media package can then use
stainless synchronization
to help predictably
package the output content.
So what happens if
something does go wrong,
such as slate input, incomplete manifesto,
and a missing DRM key?
Well, media package
actually has the ability
to 404 its endpoint.
And CloudFront is configured
with something called Origin Groups
where you specify a
primary and a secondary,
and also fail level criteria
based on HTTP status code.
When it picks up the media package
has indeed 404 to one
of its origin endpoints,
it'll automatically send that
traffic to the secondary.
But what if
it's not such a fundamental
problem, for example?
What if it's black frames,
frozen frames in the source
and it's only impacting one
of those contribution reads
going into one of the regions?
Well, building on the
previous architecture,
we have a capability
called Media Quality Aware
Resiliency to solve this,
or MQAR.
So Media Live actually has the ability
to also produce something
called an MQCS score
on each segment.
And MQCS stands for Media
Quality Confidence Score.
And that's based on those input parameters
of being black frame detection,
frozen frame detection,
or input source loss.
And that score is out of a hundred.
And each score is independently
based on its own input.
Media package actually has the ability
to use this in two locations.
It's able to use it on the input
to provide in-region failover,
and also on its output via CMSD
or Common Media Server Data.
John spoke about CMCD earlier,
CMSD is also part of that CTA spec.
And then finally,
continue to use origin
groups on CloudFront.
But instead of it being default,
we use Media Quality Score
being the origin selection
criteria, instead of the default.
The way it works
is there's a getting ahead
request into both regions.
And it basically picks the segment
that's gonna ultimately provide
that better viewing experience
to interviewers or clients.
So in summary, you can leverage
AWS Media Services and
Amazon CloudFront with MQAR
or Media Quality Aware Resiliency.
So always make your eyes on glass
and minimize the duration
of disruption events.
- We haven't got long left.
- All right, thanks Jamie.
Can you hear me?
Okay, good.
All right.
So all these measures we've taken
to analyze our stream using logging
and to make sure our origin
and encoder are available
are useless if our contribution
stream into the cloud
is not stable.
So we need to make sure our
contribution stream is reliable
just as the rest of the
chain on the encoder,
the origin and CloudFront.
So how do we make sure our source
is just as reliable as our delivery?
Well, some of the things
that we require in our source
are consistency.
We need a reliable source.
We need coverage of that source
of wherever our event happens to be.
And we need it to be private
because usually the source
coming into the cloud
is our highest quality mezzanine feed.
So we don't want anybody
to be able to access that
as it's the...
You know, again, it's the
highest quality content
and we don't want that to
go into the wrong hands.
So we do have a solution for that
that a lot of customers use
and that is Direct Connect.
Direct Connect's used heavily
for stream contribution.
For consistency, it is a
dedicated connection into a region
offering up to a hundred
gigabits of connectivity.
So a lot of you all are probably
contributing content now
through some of the higher
quality lossless formats
like JPEG excess and
using 2022 dash seven.
And if you're doing things like that,
Direct Connect is extremely
helpful for things like that.
And also it is reliable.
You can have multiple
paths into the region
using Direct Connect.
And coverage is in over a
hundred locations worldwide
in 30 plus countries.
So it's probably nearby
or at the facilities that
you're broadcasting from,
like stadiums and things
like that already.
And again, it is private.
It is a private network
and we are able to add things
like media encryption on top of it,
which we'll talk about in the next slide.
So this is where Jamie spoke a little bit
about Media Connect.
So this is one of the elemental
services for entry point
of live media into the cloud.
Whether you're using Direct Connect
or internet contribution,
you can use Media Connect
for both of those use cases.
So if you're using Direct Connect,
you're probably ingesting over a VPC.
If you're using internet connectivity,
you can certainly use a VPN endpoint
and also ingest through to Media
Connect over a VPC as well.
So utilizing VPC Origins and VPT Ingest,
the whole media workflow can be private
since the CloudFront
support's pulling from a VPC
and we can ingest to a VPC as well.
And we mentioned encryption earlier.
A lot of the protocols that
we support on Media Connect
offer encryption such as
SRT and Zixi and RIST.
SRT, USC, we use quite a bit.
And enabling encryption on that's trivial.
And pretty much every encoder
out there that publishes SRT
supports encryption.
So whether you're using
internet or Direct Connect,
encryption is an option.
And especially over internet contribution,
packet loss is a thing.
You know, drop packets are a thing.
Most of these protocols
like SRT and Zixi and RIST and RTP-FEC
support error correction for an ARQ,
automated repeat request.
So this is all adjustable on Media Connect
and on the encoder.
So if you're doing
contribution over the internet,
adding a little bit of latency
and in exchange for reliability
is available in Media Connect.
So you can just...
You can add a little bit
more error correction
for known spotty connections.
And both of these protocols,
Zixi and SRT, that I mentioned,
allow for failover of the streams.
So you can have multiple ISPs contributing
over Media Connect.
And if one of them has an
issue during the live event,
it can automatically switch
over to the other one.
And then I mentioned
earlier about metrics,
they're super important.
The dashboard that we
create before the event
has CloudFront on there
so we know if there's an
issue with CloudFront.
Most likely it contains
metrics from the origin server
to know how the origin's performing.
And if we're using DRM or ad insertion,
those metrics are also available.
But we can also add ingest
metrics to the dashboard as well
for ARQ recovery drop packets.
So we have a quick view
on whether our ingest is having issues,
whether it's CloudFront or the origin.
For SRT, which is one of
the most common protocols
for ingest over the internet,
these are the recommended metrics
that we see being used for
dashboards for Media Connect.
So these are the ones
that you know, for the largest live events
that customers are actually
monitoring really closely
for ingest quality.
So next, Jes Palmer's going to come over.
She's from New England Sports
Network home of the Red Sox.
And she's gonna speak a
little bit about her platform.
- Thank you.
So NESN is not the largest RSN,
but we are actually the first RSN
to offer a direct to consumer
live streaming app in 2022.
As a regional sports network,
NESN has a small digital team,
mostly me and my boss, (laughing)
serving a growing user base.
Armed with basic streaming knowledge,
we were able to easily learn
and manage the stream flow
through AWS Cloud Services.
RSNs like NESN have unique
streaming challenges.
They must deliver high
quality, low latency,
live and on-demand sports content,
and force regional broadcasting rights,
and handle unpredictable traffic spikes,
all while maintaining strong
security and compliance.
Additionally, unlike many
national distributors
who receive SRT feeds and
then retransmit those,
at NESN, we control every
step of the broadcast.
First, the game is captured by cameras,
which are connected to our
mobile production unit,
otherwise known as the truck.
It's an actual truck
with the production equipment inside it.
We have 4K cameras and HD cameras
at Fenway Park for the Red Sox
and at TD Garden for the Bruins.
For away games,
we have our own HD cameras
that travel with the teams.
The feed is then relayed over
the internet from the truck
or from the opponent's stadiums
to master control at our Boston office.
These feeds are shared directly
with our linear distributors
for fans still watching
sports the old fashioned way
through their cable subscriptions.
And additionally, the SRT
feed is routed directly to AWS
through AWS hardware encoders.
About 50% of the Red Sox
and Bruins seasons games
are home games,
which we offer in HD and 4K.
AWS makes it easy for us
to manage the availability
of our 4K stream
using an AWS elemental encoder
via Media Live for transcoding
and streaming management.
We installed Media live
anywhere on our AWS Elemental
encoder with John's help
so that we could administer
the feed through Media live
the same way we manage
our HD and UHD links
in the media live dashboard.
From the 4K source, we configured
a media live output group
that contains 4K, 2K, 1080p,
and 720p video outputs,
as well as stereo and
surround audio outputs
and closed caption outputs.
We kept the traffic...
Sorry, we kept the audio
and video tracks separate
because we found that maxing
resulted in issues with
some of the OTT players.
We used a media package V2 channel group
to create Dash and HLS origin endpoints,
again, for compatibility
on different systems.
And those origins
are then used for
CloudFront distributions.
A major advantage to using CloudFront
is that it automatically scales
to accommodate traffic variations.
So for example, if the Sox
are playing the Yankees,
we don't have to worry
about edge capacity,
CloudFront takes care of that for us.
We also occasionally get third party feeds
or one-off direct feeds
like batting practice
directly from Fenway Park
or morning skate from
Bruins Practice Arena
that we offer as digital exclusives.
And we have an HD link that we
use for those one-off events.
We use the same basic
flow for those events.
The live or third party feed
is rolled out through the HD link,
and the HD feed is transcoded
into lower output tiers
to accommodate CTV and mobile devices.
Then it's the same Media live
to Media package to CloudFront Flow.
Additionally, CloudFront
logs across all services
provide metrics and alarms
that help detect performance issues early,
maintain stream quality,
and ensure smooth delivery.
Having these logs
easily accessible and
queryable using Log Insights
is essential to a lean
digital team like ours.
In summary, CloudFront empowers NESN
to deliver reliable high
quality streams for every fan,
scale seamlessly during live sports peaks,
protect media rights and
maintain regulatory compliance,
and gain real time insights
into audience behavior and performance.
- All right.
Thanks Jes.
It's really cool.
I always love everything
that you're doing over there.
Jes spoke a little bit about MediaTailor,
or it was on her diagram earlier
when she gave her demonstration.
MediaTailor is a managed service
under the Elemental umbrella
that does ad replacement and
ad insertion for live streams
or on-demand streams, actually.
And this workflow here,
again, it uses MediaTailor,
but a lot of the other
ad insertion platforms
work in a similar manner.
When you're trying to
monetize your streams,
it adds a whole new set of challenges.
In effect of...
This is called dynamic ad insertion.
And just by the name, you add
a dynamic element into it.
Every single manifests for
end users are personalized
because they have ads
destined for that end user.
Whether you're using linear ads
or whether you're using
some of the newer formats
like Squeeze Back or Pause Ads.
So before, we've always
talked about scaling
and CloudFront scaling the origin.
When we talk about ad insertion,
the origin becomes that
much more important
because every single
request from the end user,
whether you have a thousand
or a million users,
are going directly to the origin,
and the origin's modifying
the manifest in real time.
So it's really important
that your origin can scale with
your viewers appropriately.
When you configure a
CloudFront for advertising,
you're gonna have a couple more
behaviors being configured.
For your manifest, you're
no longer caching that,
you're sending them directly
to the origin server,
which is then modifying
every single manifest
going to the end user.
Then the MediaTailor in this case
is going to make a call
to an advertiser upstream,
whether it's Spring Surf, Freewill,
any of those ad platforms.
And those must scale as well
because every single request
is gonna be a unique
request to an ad server.
So it's really important
when we add dynamic ad
insertion into a platform
that we look into that as an origin.
As well as DRM platforms as well,
you know, they're typically
not behind CloudFront.
MediaTailor's actually
recently added some features
to help with the ad platform,
'cause if everybody's going to
an ad break at the same time
and we're hitting a million viewers
to an ad platform all at once,
the ad platform, whoever it
might be, can't handle that.
So MediaTailor actually has the ability
to pre-fetch ads before an ad break
and stack a request to an ad server.
So these are some of the
really important considerations
when you're adding monetization
to your live stream.
Again, whether it's linear ad replacement,
overlay, squeeze back,
any of the newer formats,
there's a lot more considerations
that you have to look over,
specifically with the origin server,
the origin server being
the ad insertion provider.
So I wanna hand it back over
to Jamie for the summary.
And yeah-
- Cheers.
Thank you.
- So to wrap things up,
we wanted to aim this talk
about, you know, thinking of ways
that you can...
Or to help you deliver those events
successfully and at scale.
We want you to remember these key things
when you start planning for
your next large scale event.
So firstly, observability
is critical, right?
Whether that's dashboards,
data collection,
and through real time logs and Kinesis,
but think about how you
could use other data points
such as CMCD and CMSD
to also help you with your observability.
Architecture actually...
Oh, sorry.
Architecture design
can actually also go beyond
just the encode and
the origination, right?
We covered AWS Elemental Media Services,
but also remember
like how to leverage other infrastructure
to help you absorb some of that traffic,
such as Embedded POPs and Origin Shield.
Security is also a
really layered approach.
There's not really one
mechanism that fits all.
So think about your
end-to-end security strategy
covering, you know, tokenization,
IP blocking, GA blocking,
and using mechanisms like
CloudFront functions and AWS WAF.
And then finally, monetization
can be just more than a
subscription payment, right?
You can use server side ad insertion
to help you monetize your content
using services such as MediaTailor.
So if you want to learn about
or continue reading on
some of these topics
that we discussed today,
or want to deploy the samples,
here are the links to them.
(silence)
And finally, if you're interested
in leveling up your skills on
network and content delivery,
I thoroughly recommend you
check out Skill Builder.
So that concludes our session today.
Thanks for joining us.
Hope you found it useful
to kind of think about, you know,
the next things you need to look out
for those large scale events.
Just a quick reminder,
please go to the re:Invent app
to submit your feedback
on the session today
so that we can help improve it.
But yeah, we'll be hovering around
if you've got any questions
for what we spoke about today,
but enjoy the rest of your
time here at re:Invent.
(audience applauds)